The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: So this is
actually almost near the end.
So this is actually the last
lecture on transport protocols.
And then on
Wednesday, my plan is
to talk about how
many of the things
we have studied in this
class apply to the internet.
It will be a history lesson
about communication networks.
And I'll talk in specific terms
about two interesting problems.
One of them is a
problem we'll start
on today, which is how you
pick these window sizes.
And I'll talk about
how TCP does this.
And it's one of the
pretty amazing result
that was only invented in
the mid-1980s or late 1980s.
And the second thing
I want to talk about,
when I talk about this history
of the internet from, say, 1960
to today, I'll talk
about how people
can hijack other
people's routes and be
able to attract traffic
that doesn't actually
belong to them.
So apparently, now
there are people
who are doing it illegally.
But apparently, now
some governments
are also doing
this sort of thing.
So it's an interesting
thing to understand,
how it is that some of the
routing protocols we studied
are not secure.
So I'll do that on Wednesday.
And then we'll
wrap up next week.
So today, the plan
is to continue
to talk about
transport protocols,
in particular, about
sliding windows.
So just to refresh
everyone's memory,
the problem is that you have
a best effort network, where
packets could be lost,
packets could be reordered,
packets could be duplicated,
and delays in the network
are variable.
And what we would like to
provide to applications, like,
for example, your web browser
or your web client or server,
is an abstraction where the
application just writes data
into some layer, and the
application on the other side
reads data from a layer,
and this transport layer
deals with providing in
order reliable delivery.
So we looked at the first
version of that protocol, which
is stop and wait.
And it had a few
nice ideas in it.
The first-- all simple ideas--
the first is to use
sequence number,
and then to have
acknowledgments,
and then to retransmit
after a timeout.
And I didn't actually
talk about how
to do adaptive timers and the
low pass exponentially weighted
moving average filter.
But we started that recitation.
And if I have time, I'll
come back to that today.
But my assumption is that you've
already seen how to do that.
But then we concluded that the
throughput of the stop and wait
protocol is not very high.
It's sometimes a good idea.
For example, to get reliable
delivery between this access
point here and your
computer right now,
a stop and wait protocol
is perfectly reasonable.
We'll understand why later on.
But the short answer why is
because the round-trip time
between this access point here
and your laptop is quite small.
And because it's a really
small round-trip time,
you're able to get one
packet per round-trip time--
or in [INAUDIBLE]
packet losses, it's
less than one packet
per round-trip time,
but roughly about one
packet per round-trip time.
But the round-trip time is
on the order of microseconds.
One packet per round-trip
time can give you a throughput
that's quite large.
And therefore, if the link
speed is 10 megabits per second,
and you're able to send
1,000-byte packet in, say,
20 microseconds, if
you take the ratio,
that's probably going to be
bigger than the link speed.
And therefore,
you're going to get
of the order of the link speed.
And therefore, you're not
going to underutilize the link.
But now, if the round-trip
time were 100 milliseconds,
and you were able to send
just one packet every 100
milliseconds, it would be slow.
And to solve that problem,
we looked at this idea
of a sliding window.
This is just pipelining.
It just says, rather than
have one packet unacknowledged
at any point in
time, we're going
to have a value w that the
sender decides, decides
upon this value.
And the semantics
of a window are
that we're going to have
w unacknowledged packets
in the system between the
sender and the receiver.
Now, technically, it's
at most w packets.
Because from time to time,
you might have transients,
where you have less than
w packets, because you're
about to send the next packet.
Or if you get toward
the end of the file,
and you run out of
data to send, you're
clearly going to have
fewer than w packets.
So the technical definition of
a window, a fixed-size window,
says that if the window
is w, then the semantics
are that we will have no more
than w unacknowledged packets
in the system.
Now, that's not the
only possible definition
of the window, but that's our
current operating definition
of the window.
So then the rules at the
center are very simple.
When you get an acknowledgment
from the receiver,
as long as it's
an acknowledgment
for a packet that you have
sent, and that packet has not
previously been
acknowledged, then you now
know that packet has
been acknowledged.
So you remove it from your
list of knowledge packets,
and you send a new packet.
The packet you send,
the new packet you send,
is the smallest sequence number
that you haven't sent so far.
OK?
It's the very simple rule.
And separately,
there's a calculation
of the timeout, an exponential
moving average filter that
calculates the average
value of that timeout,
the smooth estimate of the
timeout, a similar calculation
that finds the
deviation from the mean.
And you pick a return
special timeout
that is some number of
deviations away from the mean,
for example, four times
the smoothed estimate.
If that timer fires,
and you haven't
received an acknowledgment,
you retransmit the packet.
It's a very simple idea.
So I'm going to show
now what happens
in some pictures with
the sliding window, when
you have packet loss.
So it's the same picture
as the last time,
except now we have a packet--
packet 2 is lost.
The sender doesn't know
that it's lost yet.
So packet 1 goes here.
Packet 2 is lost.
This side was supposed
to be packet 3.
The sent-- packet 4 is
sent, and packet 5 is sent.
And the window size
in this example is 5.
So now, when the first packet
gets its acknowledgment,
the window slides
to the right by 1.
And at this point,
we send packet 6.
And the window is now packet
2 to 6, the sent packet 6.
And now, in the meantime,
what's going to happen
is, when packet--
packet 2 doesn't reach,
but packet 3 reaches.
when packet 3 reaches, 3
gets an acknowledgment.
The receiver says
that it's received 3.
When it receives 3, what's the
next packet that's transmitted?
The packet that's
transmitted is 7.
Now, let me ask you
a question here.
The sender got packet
A1 and packet A3--
sorry, acknowledgment A1
and acknowledgment A3.
Now, it the sender
were calculating
the expected next
acknowledgment,
it knows that after
A1, it should get A2,
and it now got A3.
So why doesn't it just
re-send packet 3 right now?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: It
could have been delayed.
Now, yes, it could
have been delayed.
But if it were delayed,
wouldn't 3, packet 3,
have also been delayed?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Why not?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: All
packets are delayed.
So the question is,
what is it about--
the delay is one
part of the answer,
but what is it specifically
about that delay that has
caused this to--
I mean, if a packet
gets delayed,
and packets are
sitting in a queue,
if the first packet in
the queue was delayed,
then the remaining
packets are also
going to get delayed,
because they're
sitting behind that
packet in the queue.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Does it depend
on the size of the packet?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
Well, so far, let's
assume that you have a network
where packets are delayed,
and delays are variable.
And you have a switch, right?
And the switch
has a queue in it.
And let's say that you
have-- in this example,
you have packet 1 and 2 and 3.
But in fact, packet
2 was lost, and you
don't know that, this packet 3.
That's one case.
But in the other case, if packet
2 were not actually lost--
if packet 2 were lost, and you
got an acknowledgment for 1
and an acknowledgment for 3,
if packet 2 were legitimately
lost, then it's certainly
correct behavior
for the sender to send,
when it receives A3,
to retransmit packet 2.
So clearly, you're
going after a case
here, where 2 exists,
but wasn't lost.
In other words, if the sender
were to retransmit packet 3--
oh, sorry, packet 2
when it receives A3,
she said that that's wrong,
because it could have gotten
delayed.
But what kind of
delay would delay
packet 2 but not packet 3?
Or what kind of
delay equivalently
would delay A2 but not A3?
If it's sitting
behind the same queue,
and the queue is serviced
in that order, I mean,
if this packet was delayed, this
package would also be delayed.
And this packet's behind
this packet in the queue.
So what else could it be?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
So the word I'm looking
for is that packets could
get reordered in the network.
In fact, the
reordering could happen
even if there were
no variable delays,
like, no queuing
delays in the network.
I mean, you could
just have a switch
that you have a switch here.
It could be that packet
2 gets sent that way,
and packet 3 gets sent this way.
Here's a very concrete
example of how this would
happen, from your previous lab.
It could be that the network
had a certain set of routes,
and packets were
going along this path.
And then maybe there
was a failure before,
and a new link showed up.
Or the failure healed.
And the routing protocol
converged to pick this path,
going forward.
And this new packet 3,
that showed up after 2,
gets sent along this path.
And it could easily be
the case that this path
has a lot shorter delay to the
destination than that path.
And therefore, what would happen
is that the receiver, packet 3
would arrive before packet 2.
So in other words, if I had a
network where no packets ever
got reordered, no
acknowledgments
got-- no data packets
got reordered,
and no ACKs got
reordered, then, in fact,
it was perfectly good
behavior for the sender,
at this point, when
it observes A3,
to go ahead and resend packet 2.
Because I'm guaranteeing
to you that there's
no reordering in the network.
But in general, the networks and
packet switch networks, I mean,
they get a lot of
their robustness
to failure and
resilience to failure
because they send
packets any which way.
Their only job is to get
packets to the destination
with as high a
likelihood as they can,
which means packets are
allowed to get reordered.
And therefore, it's not
correct for packet 2
to get retransmitted
when you get A3.
OK?
So let's keep going.
So what is the
next packet that's
going to be sent, when you
get A3, in this picture?
It's 7.
Because the sender's
rule is very simple.
Have I seen the ACK before?
No.
Is this ACK corresponding to a
packet that I've sent before?
Remember, we need that
check, because it's
possible that a flaky--
there's some bug on
the receiver side.
So is it is an ACK
that corresponds
to a packet I've sent before?
Yes.
Send the next
in-sequence packet.
So it sends packet 7.
At this point, we're going to
lose the beautiful animation.
Because each of
these things takes
an endless amount of time.
So I just produced
the full picture.
I just wish I had the
patience to sit and do
the full animation.
But I ran out of patience.
So anyway, you sent
packet 7 at this point.
And then, when you receive
A4, you send packet 8.
When you receive A5,
you send packet 9; A6,
you send packet 10.
Now, let me ask this question.
At this point in time, when you
receive this acknowledgment,
A5, and you sent packet
9, what is the window?
That is, what is the set
of packets in the window?
The window is 5,
the window size,
but the window size corresponds
to some list of packets
that are in the window.
What is that set of packets
or that list of packets?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN:
2, 7, 8, 9, 10.
This is important.
This is 2, 7, 8, 9, 10.
These packets are
not in sequence.
It's very tempting to say,
the windows [INAUDIBLE]
five packets.
So if I've sent out 10, the
window must be 10, 9, 8, 7, 6.
Well, that's not true.
The window just says,
here's the number
of unacknowledged packets.
The number of unacknowledged
packets is 5, in this case.
All right, let's keep going.
When 10 arrives, when
10 is sent out here,
and then at some
later point in time,
we get an acknowledgment
for 7, we send out 11.
When we get 8, we send out 12.
At this point in time, the
window is 12, 11, 10 9, and 2.
At some point, the
center times out.
And the timeout is picked
to be conservative.
That's why we take
the smooth average.
We take the deviation.
Because we don't actually
want to transmit a packet
that hasn't genuinely been lost.
The reason for
that is oftentimes,
when you start seeing
weird behavior like this,
like a presumed
missing packet, you're
not actually sure
if it's missing
or if it's just delayed, as was
pointed out before, because it
took a different route.
Something strange is
going on in the network.
And causing
retransmission to happen
of a packet that hasn't
actually been lost
makes things worse, because it
adds more load onto the system
right about the time when
there's something fishy going
on in the network.
So the last thing
you want to do,
when something is under stress,
is to add more stress to it.
That's why the timeouts
are conservative.
Any time the sender, in
any protocol like this,
retransmits a packet that
is not actually lost,
that's considered a
spurious retransmission.
It's considered a retransmission
that is just not a good thing.
Now, actually, our protocol,
as we've described,
it has some wonderful
nice properties.
And I'll show later on--
maybe you can read about this
in the book--
that it actually is the
best possible protocol
you can come up with in
an asymptomatic sense.
In other words,
no other protocol,
if you ran it for a long
time, would actually
get higher throughput in
a network that had losses.
So it has some nice properties.
But it has this
one bad property,
which is that, in
fact, this protocol,
in the way these
acknowledgments are structured,
ends up with a lot of
spurious retransmissions.
Or they could end up with a lot
of spurious retransmissions.
Can you kind of see
why this protocol
could be that we follow this
discipline extremely nicely,
that timeouts are conservative.
So the only timeout,
when we are really,
really sure when a packet--
we don't get an acknowledgment,
is when we time out,
and we wait a long time.
But the protocol could still
have spurious retransmissions.
Can anyone see why there's
a very peculiar behavior
of this property of
this protocol that
comes from the way in which
these acknowledgments work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
So this protocol has
a peculiar problem,
which is that all packets and
acknowledgments are essentially
the same.
They contain the
same information.
If you lose a packet or
you lose an acknowledgment
for that packet, the sender
can't tell the difference.
Now, this is, therefore,
not necessarily
the best protocol, in the sense
that, if you have a path--
here is an extreme case.
So I have a path where
there's no packet
losses going from me to you,
and I'm sending data to you.
And coming back, the
packet loss rate is 25%.
This protocol has this
unfortunate property
that I believe that 25% of my
transmissions are lost to you.
In fact, you've got every
single packet I've sent.
It's just that I don't
see the acknowledgments
for those specific packets.
And therefore, I'm going to
retransmit all those packets
to you, leading to
spurious retransmissions.
So we don't have to worry
about it for the lab
or for the class, but
as a design problem,
can you invent a protocol
that fix this problem?
Can you modify this
protocol, or come up
with an idea of your own,
which has the property that--
pick the design point that is
the sender-to-receiver path
is generally loss-free.
But let's say that the
receiver-to-send path
has a high loss.
And by the way, this
is not hypothetical.
This is what happens in
wireless networks a lot.
Because that base station
sitting in some cell tower that
has a huge amount of power--
it's powered in-- it consumes
probably kilowatts these days.
So they can blast at whatever is
the maximum allowed by the FCC.
And your poor,
little, dinky phone
is sending acknowledgments.
And the thing is running
out of battery all the time.
So they're carefully
trying to figure out,
what's the minimum power
at which I can transmit?
So in fact, these asymmetric
conditions are not unrealistic.
They're quite realistic.
So if I ran this protocol
on a network like that,
it would be probably
a bad thing.
So what would you
do to the protocol?
Yes?
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Send multiple
acknowledgments-- yeah, you
could send multiple
acknowledgments to every time.
So you'd be doubling.
Yeah, that's a little bit--
but it's the right kind of idea.
You want some sort
of redundancy.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
That's actually not a bad idea.
In a sense, you're sending
multiple acknowledgments,
but you're not just
blindly sending
multiple acknowledgment.
But any time you send
an acknowledgment,
you could also say--
sending the list of all
packets you've received so far
is a huge amount.
Because if I send you a
gigabyte movie, or something,
I mean, by the
end of that movie,
you're just sending me a
lot of acknowledgments.
So you don't quite
want to do that.
But remember, the
receiver has some idea.
If it knew the
window size, it would
have some idea of what the
number of things at the center.
You could do something even
simpler than all of that.
One thing you could do is
that the receiver, when
it acknowledged the
packet, wouldn't just
acknowledge packet 7,
when it got packet 7,
but it might be able to send
a cumulative acknowledgment.
In other words, it
could say, that when
I send an acknowledgment,
I guarantee
to you that everything I've
received up to this point--
I'm sorry.
I guarantee to you that all
packets up to that point
I have received.
So if I tell you that
my acknowledgment is 17,
I guarantee you that
there's nothing before 17
that I've not received.
And then I could, in addition,
in the acknowledgment,
tell you a little bit about
some of the later packets I've
received or some of the later
packets that might be missing.
So you can make this
protocol have a little bit
more redundancy.
And if you do that, and
you apply almost everything
else I've taught,
you get TCP, which is
an extremely popular protocol.
But that's about the only
difference of significance
between our protocol and TCP.
Now, interestingly,
our protocol,
when you actually
have loss rates
in the forward and
reverse directions
that are roughly the
same, our protocol
actually does a little better
than what TCP happens to do.
But TCP is good at dealing
with the reverse path having
a higher degree of packet loss.
OK.
So the other question I want to
ask people here, at this point,
is let's say that you have
a receiver that's running
on an extremely simple device.
So you don't want to
have a lot of storage.
Now, why would you need storage,
before I get to that question?
Let's take this picture here.
So packet 2 hasn't
yet been received.
But in the meantime,
the receiver
has gotten packets 3 and 4
and 5, all the way up to 12.
So what does the
receiver have to do?
Well, the receiver, remember,
before it delivers it
to the application, it has
to hold on to those packets.
It can't deliver packet 3 to
the application and packet 4
to the application.
Because the guarantee that
the receiver is giving
is that all packets
will be delivered
in exactly the same order
in which they were sent.
So the receiver has got
to hold onto those packets
until packet 2 shows up.
Does that make sense?
OK.
How big can that
receiver's buffer become?
How big do you need to make it?
Like, if you were implementing
this on a computer,
if you want to
allocate memory for it,
how big do you need to make it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: What?
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Big enough
to handle the timeout--
good.
How big can the timeout be?
Well, the timeout can
be some finite number.
But think about what happens.
Think about the timeout happens.
You retransmit packet 2.
And packet 2 is lost again.
Now, in the meantime, the
protocol is going to continue.
Because all these
other packets are
going to keep getting
acknowledgments,
and they're going to
keep causing the sender
to keep sending packets.
So if packet 2's
retransmission were lost,
we're going to be
at this point here.
We're still going to be
sending, at this point
in time, packet
13 and whatever--
13 and 14 and 15 and
16, and so forth, right?
Now, packet 2 could
just keep getting lost.
I mean, it may happen
with low probability,
but there's a probability
that it'll happen.
So how big does the
receiver's buffer
have to be in this
implementation,
in the worst case?
Well, let's say that you don't
know how big the file is.
It's a continuous stream
of packets that are sent.
I mean, is that a bound?
In the worst case,
is that a real
bound on the size of the buffer?
Or can it grow to be as
big as the entire stream
that you're sending?
It can grow to be
really, really big.
Now, this is a
potential problem.
Because it can keep growing
and growing and growing.
At some point, you're
going to run out.
You might run out of space.
When you start to
run out of space,
it's tempting to just
throw things out.
So let's say that the
receiver implements it.
Somebody implements this
protocol and just says,
I'm going to just
have 100 packets.
The sender is running
with a window size of 5.
I'm just going to have a buffer
of 100 packets, which says,
the maximum number of packets
I'm going to hold in my buffer,
before I start discarding
later packets, is 100.
Does this protocol work?
Is it correct if I do that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like a receiver
just never acknowledges
[INAUDIBLE] receives it
[INAUDIBLE].
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: OK, but
what if I acknowledge a packet
as soon as I get it?
OK, if you acknowledge a
packet as soon as you get it,
the receiver's discipline, the
guarantee it should provide,
is if it acknowledges
a packet, then
it's told the sender that
it's got the packet, which
means the sender will
never retransmit it,
which means it shouldn't
throw the packet away.
So as long as the receiver
only throws out packets
that it doesn't
acknowledge, you're OK.
Does that make sense?
So the discipline is it's just
like writing a legal contract,
right?
That's what protocols are.
It's just a bunch
of legal contracts,
and you try to make them
as simple as possible.
And you try hard, and you
end up with 200 pages.
But that's what lawyers also
say-- yeah, it's really simple.
But then you've got
all these clauses.
But the reality
is that you've got
to deal with all these
[INAUDIBLE] cases.
So protocols are nothing
more than contracts
that both sides agree upon.
And the contract here
from the receiver
is actually pretty simple.
It says, if I send
you an acknowledgment,
it means that I'm not
throwing the packet away.
What happens if I treat this
protocol to do a little bit
differently at the receiver?
When I get a packet,
if it's in order,
I deliver it to the application.
And after I deliver
it to the application,
I send an acknowledgment.
OK?
So in other words, I only send
an acknowledgment to the sender
after it's delivered
up to the application.
Otherwise, I don't.
What happens to this
protocol if I do that?
Does it perform the
same as what I describe?
And remember, there's
a subtle difference.
The only difference
is, in this protocol
as I've described it, the
receiver gets a packet,
sends an acknowledgment,
and then holds on to it
in a buffer, if the packet's
not the next packet in order.
The modification I'm proposing
is the receiver gets a packet,
and only when it delivers
it up to the application,
does it send an acknowledgment.
Otherwise, it doesn't
send acknowledgment.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Is it
just like stop and wait?
AUDIENCE: I think so,
because [INAUDIBLE]..
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: But if
packets are not being lost,
it's doing a lot better
than stop and wait, right?
If packets are not
getting lost, it's doing--
would you agree that if
packets are not lost,
it does better
than stop and wait?
In fact, if packets
are not lost,
is there any difference
between my protocol
and this [INAUDIBLE] modified?
No.
OK.
But yet, you had a good thought.
It looks like stop and wait.
When does it look
like stop and wait?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
So that modification is,
when packets are lost,
it looks like stop and wait.
Now, this is not a
mere academic thing.
So it turns out that
there was a period of time
in the '90s, where somebody in
Linux TCP had the bright idea--
it seemed like a bright idea--
that that's what they would do.
So for a period of time,
there was a Linux TCP,
where they said, well,
it's all very complicated.
Because what would happen was
that sometimes, the machine
would crash.
And the sender thought that the
packet had been acknowledged,
but it hadn't actually
been delivered up
to the application.
So let's just make it so
the packets get delivered
to the application, and only
when the application does
the read--
for those of you who've
done this sort of thing--
from the socket buffer, and it's
been out in the application,
and out of the
operating system, that's
when we'll send
the acknowledgment.
And you [? read, ?] seemed OK.
People said, that
seems reasonable.
And Linux, the way it
seems, things seem to work,
as people try out
a lot of stuff.
And then I suggest,
from time to time,
somebody declares that
something is right.
So anyway, they tried this out.
And it actually
didn't work as well.
And the reason for
that is, if you
don't run on a high enough
packet loss rate network,
then what could happen is
that you may get stuck.
And it's very hard to notice
these performance problems.
Correctness problems
are one thing,
because the other side stops.
It stops working.
And you can corner it down.
But this simple tweak, that
looks perfectly reasonable,
is actually a
performance problem.
And it doesn't show
up all the time.
It actually shows up
only when the packet loss
rate is reasonably high.
So these are all
examples of reasons
why these protocols are
not completely obvious
and require a fair amount
of care to get it to work.
Are there any questions
about any of the stuff?
Is this all clear?
OK.
What I want to do now is to
show a picture of something
called a sequence plot,
which is a very useful tool
in understanding how these
protocols actually work.
So what you do to produce
one of these plots
is you run your protocol.
And you plot out--
at the sender,
you plot out the times at
which the sender sent out
every sequence number, every
time it transmitted a packet.
And you plot that out
as a function of time.
The y-axis is the
sequence number.
The x-axis is time.
And similarly, every
time the sender
gets an acknowledgment, you plot
that out on the trace as well.
So you look at these two traces.
OK, this is a trace of packet
transmissions, data packet
transmissions, and this is a
trace of ACK packet receptions.
And you look at this picture.
Now, the moment you get
a picture like this,
there's a few things you
can immediately conclude.
The first thing you
can conclude is,
that if I look at the distance
between the data and the ACK,
when there are no
losses happening,
if I look at that distance,
that tells me the window size.
Because that's the
number of packets.
Because the last acknowledgment,
every time an acknowledgment
happens, you send
out a new packet.
Therefore, the distance in
sequence numbers between--
in one of these vertical
slices, when there are no packet
losses, is the window size.
You can also read off the
typical round-trip time
of the connection.
Because the round-trip
time is the time
between when a packet,
data packet, was sent
and when you got an
acknowledgment for it.
So you can read
that off as well.
Those two pictures, there's an
easy way for you in your lab
9 to produce these pictures.
So if you're running into
things where things look slow,
things look bad, you should just
put up one of these pictures,
and then it'll
usually become pretty
apparent what's going on.
What may happen is
that initially, things
look like this.
And all of a
sudden, things stop.
And you can start
to see, well, I'm
not getting
acknowledgments, or I'm not
sending data the right way.
And these are very useful to
understand what is going on.
And generally
speaking, these are
useful to uncover performance
issues rather than correctness.
I mean, correctness,
usually, you
can iron out before
you get to this stage.
The retransmission
timeout is the time
between when you send
a packet and when
you send the retransmission
for the packet.
In this particular picture,
the deviation from the mean
was small.
And that's why the
retransmission timeout
is only a little bit bigger
than the mean round-trip time.
Every time you see a packet
that's off of that sequence
[INAUDIBLE]---- so you
see packets here.
The pluses are data packets.
And then you see
something going normally.
And then you see a lower
sequence number retransmitted,
sent here.
That's a retransmission.
So you see, normally, the new
packets are all sent there.
But the retransmissions
show up before.
So these are examples
of retransmissions,
and these are
examples of packets
that were retransmitted more
than once, because they're
timing out multiple times.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
So the window size-- what's the
definition of the window size?
The maximum number of
unacknowledged packets.
So the maximum number of
unacknowledged packets,
when there are no packet
losses that have happened,
is the difference between the
last packet you transmitted
and the last
acknowledgment you got.
Because every time you
got an acknowledgment,
you send a new packet.
And initially, you
send out w packets.
So if you continue that, so
you initially send 1 to 5,
then you send 2 to 6, 3 to 7.
And the last ACK you had was
2, when you sent out 3 to 7.
So that distance tells
you the window size.
I might be off by 1.
It's probably the
last packet you
sent minus the last
acknowledgment you got plus 1,
is the window size, or minus
1, something like that.
You've got to get that
right on the quiz.
Fortunately, I don't have
to get it right here.
[LAUGHTER]
And then, some of these
things here are later x's.
And these are
acknowledgments that show up.
So these are packets that got
retransmitted multiple times.
These are
acknowledgments that are
for these retransmitted packets.
And I say most probably, because
I can't actually be sure.
In principle, it could be
that this acknowledgment here
is for this packet, is
for this data packet,
that was actually originally
transmitted over here,
rather than for
this retransmission.
It's, in principle, possible
that this acknowledgment
was sent by the receiver
upon the reception
of a packet over here.
It's just that it's unlikely.
It's more likely
that it was this,
because that's the
round-trip time that's
consistent with that RTT.
But you can't actually be sure.
All you know is that this was
an acknowledgment for that data
packet.
But most likely, it was
for the retransmission.
OK, so these sequence
traces are generally pretty
helpful and useful
in understanding
the performance of
transport protocols,
particularly sliding
window protocols.
So any questions?
OK.
So now I'm going to turn
to the last remaining
issue for these transport
protocols, which is analogous
to we did a calculation of
the throughput of the stop
and wait protocol.
I want to look at the throughput
of the sliding window protocol.
OK.
And I want to explain that
by first actually explaining
what the problem is.
And then I want to
go back and tell you
about a very beautiful result,
very widely applicable result,
applies to everything from
networking to how long
you're going to wait to get
served at a restaurant, called
Little's Law.
It's a remarkable result, very
simple, and widely applicable.
Everybody should know it.
So the question here is,
what's the throughput
of sliding window?
And in particular, if
I had run a protocol
in a network that looks like
this-- so I have a sender.
I have a receiver.
There's some network
path in between.
And of course, this has
a bunch of switches here.
And I want to know what is the
throughput of the protocol.
And what I would like
a few to tell you what
the throughput is in terms of.
So the sender has a window size
w, according to this protocol.
For now, we'll assume that
there's no packet loss.
That is, acknowledgment
data packets are not lost,
and acknowledgments
are not lost.
If I have time
today, I'll come back
to explaining what
happens with packet loss.
Otherwise, we'll pick it
up in recitation tomorrow,
or I'll point you to
the place in the book.
It's just a simple
calculation that expands.
The more important part is
when there are no losses.
Now, I'll also
assume that there's
links of different rates here.
And one of these links on
the path between sender
and receiver is the link
that is the bottleneck link.
In other words, no matter
what you do or who you bribe,
you cannot send packets faster
than the speed of that link.
For simplicity, I'll assume
that there's one bottleneck.
The general results
apply, even though there
are multiple bottlenecks.
But I'll assume that there's
some bottleneck here.
And I'll assume that its
rate as c packets per second.
And I will assume here,
that because there's
a bottleneck, in
general, packets
may show up faster than
the bottleneck can handle.
And if they do,
they sit in a queue.
And because I've
constructed the problems
so packets don't
get lost, the queue
can have an arbitrary length.
It could be potentially--
it could grow unbounded.
Though, in reality, it
won't, because the sender
has a fixed window size of w.
Now, all of this
analysis and calculation
will apply when there are many,
many people transmitting data,
sharing this bottleneck.
So you can have multiple set
senders to multiple receivers,
and they'll all share
this link in some way.
And for now, today,
all I'll assume
is that there's one
user of the network.
It's not hard to extend the same
calculation to multiple users.
And the question is,
what is the throughput
in terms of the window size and
in terms of these other things?
Now, in order to
answer this question,
it'll turn out that
the throughput depends
on the window size, and
also on the round-trip time,
and also on the loss
rate, and also on--
in a certain mode,
it will depend on c.
It can't exceed c.
OK?
But in order to
understand how to solve
these kinds of
questions, there's
a more general result
that's more widely
applicable, called Little's Law,
which I want to tell you about.
So Little's Law applies
to any queuing system.
It applies to any system where
there's some big black box
here, and the black box has
a queue sitting inside it,
and the queue
drains at some rate.
So you have a
queue sitting here.
Things arrive into the queue.
I'll call that the
arrival process,
which I'll represent by A.
And then things come out
of the queue, according
to some service process,
which I'll represent
by S. By the way,
Little is a professor at MIT.
I think he wrote this
result, this law.
Well, I don't think he
called it Little's Law,
but other people did.
So he did this work,
I think, in the 1950s.
And what's beautiful
about this result
is that it relates
three parameters.
It relates the--
I'll call it N. It relates N,
the average number of items
that you have in this
system, in the queue,
or in this black box.
It relates that to
the service rate
and to the average delay
experienced by an item that
sits inside this black box.
So let me relate
the three again.
It relates N, which is
the average number, to D,
which is the average delay--
so I'm going to put a bar above
the fact that it's an average--
to lambda, which is
the average rate.
Now, the result applies
to a stable system.
What that means is it
applies to a system
where the queue doesn't
grow unbounded to infinity.
In other words, it
applies to a system
where the service rate-- if
the arrivals are persistently
bigger than the service, then
it doesn't matter what you do.
The queue is going
to grow to infinity,
and the delay is going
and N is going to
grow to infinity.
So you're going to get
a relationship that's
not of much practical use.
But otherwise, if the
rate at which things
come out of the system, in
a stable system, is lambda--
which, if it's a
stable system, the rate
at which things enter the
system can't exceed it either.
But it relates the
service rate lambda
for a stable system that doesn't
grow unbounded to N entity.
OK?
So let me give this
first by example.
How many of you guys
have used the food truck?
All right, so last week, I
did a little experiment there.
And I found that--
this is all real data.
I found that, at least
the [? Thai ?] truck,
they seem to take about 20
seconds per person, on average.
OK?
And when I showed
up there-- and this
wasn't an average calculation.
But I showed up there, and
there were 20 people ahead of me
in the line.
And the question,
of course, is I
don't care how many
people there are in line.
What I care about is, how
long do I have to wait?
Assuming that the
random sample I did
was the average, which who
knows if it was or not,
looking at these two numbers,
what's the waiting time?
In other words, what's D?
10 minutes?
Is it?
I didn't wait 10 minutes.
How do you get 10?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: I see.
It might be.
So I got 30.
So I had it as 20.
All right, it might be 10.
Why is it 10?
How do you conclude
that it was 10?
Who said 10?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Why?
AUDIENCE: Well, so it'd be like,
[? if you have ?] 30 people,
then you have [INAUDIBLE]
[? per person ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Yeah.
Right.
So what this says--
what you did was
you just said that D must be
equal to N over lambda, right?
Or N is lambda
times D. So if you
say that it's 20 seconds per
person, is 3 people per minute.
So what you do is you do 30
people divided by 3 per minute.
And so you get 10 minutes.
So that's about right.
That is exactly right.
So Little's Law just tells
you that the average number
of items in a system-- this
is all applicable to various
conditions on stable
systems, and so forth--
it says the average number of
items, or packets, or people,
or whatever, is equal to the
product of the rate at which
the system is servicing them
multiplied by the average delay
that they experience.
So knowing two of them, you
can calculate the third.
And what's truly, truly
remarkable about the result
is that it applies to anything
that you do in the system.
Packets could arrive,
or jobs could arrive,
or people could arrive, in
some arbitrary distribution.
They could be serviced according
to some completely arbitrary
distribution.
They don't have to be serviced
in the order in which they
arrive.
They could be shuffled around.
You could make it so
people who come in last
get serviced first.
You could do whatever, and
the result still applies.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
delay [INAUDIBLE]??
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: No.
Well, I kind of cheated
here a little bit.
This is 20 seconds per person.
But whenever I tell you a number
like that, what this really
says, that this is
3 people per minute.
So it looks like a
delay, but this is really
an inverse of a
rate in the way--
this is the inverse of the rate
in the way I've described it.
I mean, it's
intuitive to say they
take 20 seconds per person.
But when I tell you that it
takes 20 seconds per packet
or 20 seconds per person,
it looks like a delay.
But it's really a rate.
So it's important.
That's a good question.
Yeah, so this is a rate.
So this is inverse time.
And this is whatever
quantity you're dealing with.
So if you then take the ratio
of N to lambda, you get time.
OK, so why is Little's Law true?
So here's a very simple
pictorially proof
of Little's Law.
And it applies under
specific conditions.
But it turns out
these conditions
are good enough for our use.
So let's say we draw a
picture like this of a queue.
So I'm going to assume that
packets enter the queue
and leave the queue.
Now, the fact that there's
a single queue, versus
not a queue, doesn't matter.
It's any black box.
So p.packets could
get-- or information
or messages or items could
get sent from the sender.
They enter a black box, and they
get stuck out at the receiver.
And the thing applies
to that as well.
So let me plot the
number of packets
in the queue, or the number
of items in the queue,
as a function of time.
So I'm going to assume here that
capital T is extremely long.
Whenever I deal
with rates, I have
to look at what happens
over a long period of time,
and then I can calculate a rate.
So you can see that
what I've done here
is, that every time a packet
arrives or an item arrives,
the queue increments by 1.
So you can see that the
y-axis, the height of each
of those little
snippets here is 1.
And then every time it
leaves, it drops by 1.
So you get-- in a
particular execution
of whatever the
queue does, you get
a trace that looks like this.
Now, of course, in a
different execution,
the details might be different.
But if you do it for
a long enough time,
you're going to sample all
the possible evolutions
of this thing, or at
least enough of it,
so you can make
meaningful statements.
So whenever a packet arrives,
I've shown it in a color.
And I think I've matched the
color up against whenever
that packet leaves.
But in fact, the
result applies--
this particular example is
a first-in, first-out queue.
So packets leave in the
same order they were sent.
But that doesn't
have to be true.
So let me label these
packets as shown here.
Now, what I'm going
to try to do is
to relate the rate at which
packets have entered or left
the queue to the number
of items in the queue
and the average
delay experienced
by each item in the queue,
in this pictorially proof.
So the way you do
that is everything
has to do with the
fact that there
are two different
ways of looking
at the area under this curve.
And there's two different ways.
One of them relates to
the rate, and the other
relates to the average delay.
And then we're going to say, all
right, the area under the curve
is the same, and
therefore, we're
going to equate two numbers.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to divide this
up, the area under the curve,
and divide it up into rectangles
like this and associate
with each rectangle
a packet, or an item.
So I'm going to say
that A showed up here,
and it left at that point.
So this entire
period of time here
corresponds to packet
A sitting in the queue.
This entire period of
time corresponds to B. A
left at this point in time.
So now my queue
was three packets,
and they're B, C, D. And
then, at this point in time, E
showed up.
So we now have C
and D sitting here.
But now E showed up, and then
F showed up, and so forth.
So you agree that I
can divide this up
into rectangles and associate
with each little rectangle,
whose height is 1,
a particular packet.
And that is the same
packet in the queue.
So the height represents
a particular packet,
and I associate every little
piece of this queue picture
with a given packet.
Now, let's assume that we run
this experiment for a long time
T, capital T. And P packets were
forwarded through the system.
So what is the rate?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: P
packets per T seconds--
so the rate is clearly
lambda is P over T. Right?
This is easy.
OK.
Great.
Now, let's assume that
the area under the curve
is A. This is the entire
area under the curve here.
Now, this is an area
under the curve of N of T,
which is the number of
packets, as a function of T.
So if I take this area under
the curve, which is the same--
if you think of it
in continuous domain,
it's the integral of N of T--
and I divide by T,
I get that number.
Right?
You agree that the mean
number of packets in the queue
is the integral of
N of T, which is
the number of packets in the
queue at any point in time.
If I take that integral,
and I divide by capital T,
I get the mean number
of packets in the queue.
All it says is this is the total
number of packets in the queue
over--
aggregated across all time.
Therefore, to find the
average, I take the integral,
and I divide by T. That's
the definition of the mean.
All right, so now
we have two things.
We have the rate
is P over T. And we
have that the mean number
of packets in the queue
is A over T, where A is
the area under the curve.
Now, to complete the puzzle,
what we have to observe
is, that if you look at the
same area under the curve,
you can look at it in two ways.
The one way to look at
it is the mean number
of packets in the queue
is some line through here,
which is the area under
that curve divided by T.
But each of these things
accounts for a certain delay.
And the mean delay
experienced by the packet
is simply the area
under this entire curve,
but it's divided into all of the
packets that ever got forwarded
through the system.
So through this
experiment, P packets
got forwarded by the system.
And the area under
the curve also
represents a total
aggregate delay.
Because if I look at
it with this axis here,
that's the total time.
So that's the total time spent.
And if I take this entire
area under the curve,
and I look at that
and I divide by the number
of packets that I sent,
that gives me the average
time that a given packet spent
in the queue, which means that
the mean delay is A over P.
So if I take A over P and
multiply it by P over T, what
I get is A over T,
which is equal to N.
And that's Little's Law.
So now we're going to
apply Little's Law.
I mean, it's actually
a very intuitive idea.
It just says, that if I
take the rate, average rate,
and the average delay,
and I multiply the two,
I get the average number
that's sitting in the system.
So in order to
complete the picture
for the throughput of this
sliding window protocol, what
we're going to do is
to apply Little's Law
in a couple of different ways.
We're going to say, that if
the window size is w in that
protocol, and the
round-trip time is RTT--
that's the time between
when I send a packet
and get an acknowledgment back--
I first apply Little's Law.
So now I have a big black box.
I send out packets.
And every time I receive
an acknowledgment,
I send out another packet.
And I never send out
more than w packets.
So the average delay
between when I send a packet
and when I get an
acknowledgment for it is RTT.
So that's the D in the
Little's Law formula.
The number of things
that I have sitting
in this black box inside
the network, the number
of outstanding things
that I have that are
waiting to be processed, is w.
And therefore, the rate
is, by Little's Law,
N over D, which is w over RTT.
So therefore, the
throughput of this protocol
is simply equal to w over RTT.
So if I increase w, I
get higher throughput.
So if I draw this as a
function of the window size w,
I look at the throughput here.
I get a linear
increase like that.
Now, the problem with this is,
of course, you look at this
and go, well, the best way
to get higher and higher
and higher throughput is to
keep increasing the window size.
So what happens if I-- does
this keep going on forever,
that all I have to do is to
keep increasing the window size,
and then I'm getting
infinite throughput?
That's clearly not happening.
So what happens?
Why is it that it's completely
true that w over RTT
is the throughput.
So why is it that I can't just
keep increasing the window size
and get infinite throughput?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HARI BALAKRISHNAN: Well, it's
true you're bounded by c.
But yet, this formula is true.
Right?
It's true that there's
some round-trip time.
So what's really
going on, of course,
is that if you increase
the window size more
than a certain amount,
all that's going to happen
is the packets are going to
get stuck in this queue here.
And they're going to start
draining at some rate, c
packets per second.
But they're just
going to get stuck
at the back end of the queue.
When they get stuck at
the back end of the queue,
the RTT is no longer fixed.
The RTT now also starts going.
So in other words,
the throughput
is always this formula.
But initially, when the packets
are no longer in the queue--
until a certain point,
initially, you said one packet.
It goes through.
You have a window
of two packets.
They go through,
and you get ACKs.
Three packets, they go
through and get ACKs.
At some point in time, they
start to fill up the queue.
And when they start to fill
up the queue, w keeps growing.
But RTT keeps growing.
And what ends up happening is
this ratio doesn't exceed c.
So you end up with throughput
that looks like that.
And the point at which
this happens here,
this point here is
actually a product
of the minimum RTT
of the system, which
is the round-trip time in
the absence of any queuing.
I'm going to call that RTT min.
And that depends
on the propagation
delay and the
transmission delay,
but not on the queuing delay.
If there's no
queues, and there's
a certain minimum
round-trip time-- like,
it takes 100 milliseconds to
go to California and back,
or whatever.
Now, when queues start to grow,
that RTT starts increasing.
But until that point happens,
the round-trip time is RTT min.
And if I take that, and
I multiply that by c,
that's the critical
window size up
to which point there are
no queue packets that
build up in the queue.
But after that, packets start
to build up in the queue.
And there's a name given to this
product of the bottleneck link
speed, or bandwidth,
and RTT min.
It's called the
bandwidth delay product.
It's the product of the
bandwidth and the delay,
where the delay is the
minimum round-trip time.
And if I were to
draw an analogous
picture of the actual
round-trip time
as a function of
the window size,
initially, when the
window size is small,
the round-trip time is
RTT min, with some value.
And then, at this
point in time--
I want to mimic
this thing here--
you get to this point in time,
which is the bandwidth delay
product.
And then the round-trip
time starts to grow.
So this is the actual delay.
And so you look at this picture.
And a well-designed,
well-running protocol
will run with a window
size roughly around here,
where it gets the highest
possible throughput
at the lowest possible delay.
But sometimes, you might end
up running with a bigger window
size.
You're not going to get
any faster throughput,
but what you would see is
increasingly higher delay.
Now, in real networks,
designing protocols
that run at this
nice, sweet spot
is an extremely
challenging problem.
I'll get back to this
problem on Wednesday
and talk about how
people work on it.
It's still a somewhat
open problem.
In fact, it's still
an open problem
in things like cellular
wireless networks.
So I'll come back to this point.
But the main point
here is this idea
of a bandwidth delay product.